anybody running for the office of
President of the United States yeah
should agree to take a full and complete
mental competency test
simultaneously or before
with the announcement that he or she is
running and likewise but to a somewhat
lesser extent agreed to a test which
would prove that you are physically
capable of doing the job as president
yeah now understand in Trump's mind he
thinks that this full and comprehensive
test would be the Montreal cognitive
assessment where you identify a giraffe
and draw arrows on a clock and remember
five words men woman person camera TV
famously were Trump's examples but that
is not a full assessment I hate to tell
you that is like a dementia and stroke
screening brain injury screening